I hate when cops think they did you a
favor when they're like let's say they
pull you over speeding they're like so I
clocked you at 95 put down 92.
[Music]
this has been going around the interwebs
lately but there was a dude in Colorado
recently who was arrested for allegedly
driving under the influence
but police say that he tried to switch
places with his dog oh I saw this taking
the rap for it did you send that to us I
just don't see that situation being like
a win-win because even if he switched
with his dog it's like what if the cops
a dog lover though yep if that was if I
was a cop I'd be like that is so cute
this is literally I have a sucker for
that this is the reason why I don't vote
because [__] like that's voting
so I'm like what's the point who the dog
like the the level of intelligence in
this world
it's not even like the same hey give
them some credit though okay because
this dude this guy is just trying to be
great he's trying to be smart he's
trying he's he's making decisions while
intoxicating he's gonna oh you know on
economic policies are gonna affect me
but he's he's plastered though he's not
a switch with his dog yeah he's
plastered he thought in his head if
you're drunk that's a good idea it's
gonna be my default setting for any
circumstance I'm just gonna switch
places with the dog
they can't be mad at you can't be mad
the dog did it with the gun in the dog's
paw yeah exactly this is the dog ate my
homework on another level this takes the
whole like the dog farted like to a
whole different level yeah
I'll say this since I'm having more dogs
in the house
it's interesting yeah since I'm a dad
blaming um farts on dogs is like it
works out the other day
my dog took a [__] on my shoe
why because he's a [__] [__]
[__] not because when you have
puppies you have to keep an eye on them
at all times right we had leashes on
them we're about to take them out I went
to go grab like treats so I could bribe
them into walking right yeah all right
come around this dude is squatting over
my shoes oh [__] right into my shoe is
your women's shoes no the ones that he
shot on were men's wait on the whole or
like on the front right on the front
like bang that's not as bad no it's a
little you know from diarrhea well like
it's a little mushy I have too many
shoes anyway I should throw these out so
I threw them they weren't your super
rare shoes were they no dude I don't
know what the f oh dang good
the nogi just finally released so
everyone go check that out people
commented on that like it was like my
[__] ad he's on the super I thought
it was your ad no it's it's super rare
the shop but loading their new drop
there's a gold set right and then what's
the other color it was a navy blue yeah
navy blue set you can get a full no game
how do you feel when people ask ski do
ads like that do you say yes
automatically honestly I'd
I live God Did It Alex did it but like
anytime I see you being serious I'm like
I just can't help but wonder that you're
thinking I'm such a [__] [__] I I
hate that video I don't like that video
because I'm just like what are we doing
dude what is this what's the product
it's called super rare super rare I'll
totally I'll totally buy they're friends
with uh we're friends of the gym yeah
even when the gym posts like
instructionals of you like talking like
you could just tell you hate your own
voice so we're talking about dogs dude
this is just his regular coaching yeah
he hates his job like when you're being
recorded it's you just sound so over
yourself what's up guys my name is Nick
Dunn I'm an instructor here at Lionheart
Jiu Jitsu Academy and we're gonna show
you an x-guard sweep that we've been
working for these past couple weeks so
you're a spokes model too yeah I didn't
know that no not a squirrel yeah what's
a spokesman he's just a brand you do
good contact
piece of bread bro we're talking about
the dogs
print model stuff too or I've never done
print model stuff is that like in
magazines yeah yeah
no he's not naked
naked print models you do runway for
like a ghee thing if I could like move
my hips really well no you can't [__]
around again I have to be serious yeah
then I probably wouldn't do it yeah
right what it feels
if it's a friend that's like you'll do
it
but I'd be stomping my feet the whole
time
[Laughter]
yeah I have a bad attitude about it but
yeah dogs what about dogs have you guys
ever been in a a DUI or a any type of
situation yeah what's it like what's it
like I wish I wish I had my dog
when did you get a DUI oh gosh like 1963
years ago yeah like I'm like like
probably like 10 15 years ago probably
15 probably more like 15. when was it
like like legit drunk or were you like I
I don't think I was that drunk I was
driving like 30 miles an hour like on
the freeway that's pretty drunk and then
I was like I was like passing in and out
but like at that time oh [__] what the
[__] at that casino I was a champion
Drinker at that time my body
automatically knew like and so I fall
asleep and my foot would go off the
accelerator
so then I would just go Safeguard oh
yeah I would just automatically did that
so I happened to be on the freeway and
then I remember the cop pulled me over
and you know I got off the freeway and
then I did try to do all the tricks that
they do like when they put the
flashlight you're supposed to like you
know like squint because I guess when
you're drunk you don't squint you just
look right into that you look right into
the device oh that's what happened oh
[__] I was like all squinting and stuff
and then um
he's like he was super cool he was like
a really nice guy and uh he he goes like
you've been drinking I told him and then
uh he goes do you know where you are and
I go is this like a trick question thing
is I had no idea where I was going in a
car but his his badge said Orange Police
so I go is this like a trick we're in
Orange
but like so I thought it would like you
know but he was just like okay what are
you a professional comedian I know
seriously so he had me do all the tests
and uh you know the crowd work with the
cops
but you know so I found out later a lot
of that because he told me
he told me stuff he goes it's for you so
you feel so you know that you're drunk
but they can tell right off because I've
been doing this for 20 years I I know
what you're kind of gonna kind of blow
and you know we we know like the the pen
test is supposed to be the one that
really lets them know because when it
gets to this part uh when you're drunk
it starts your eyes start fluttering and
you can't control that and you don't
even know it's fluttering I didn't know
that and then um he was like I said he
was cool he put He he didn't tow my car
he he reparked it and then he put what
he thought were valuables in the glove
compartment wow this is super dude
that's a really nice car yeah really
nice and then I found out later he's
that saved me like 300 bucks what a cool
guy yeah he was really cool
um and then like after went to the
police station like did all those
paperwork stuff and he goes you want to
call you a cab I'm like uh yeah she's
supposed to be in like uh the the jail
for a night that's so it's up to the
cops discretion from what I understand
but he just he just basically I signed
the thing this is before Uber he goes
you want to call you a cab
and he goes if you go back to your car
and you move it then I'm gonna I'm gonna
um put you in like in jail like oh no no
I'm just gonna go home and so he's like
okay and the next day I woke up got a
cab to get my car
um what a cool car he was really cool so
then you went on a date with the cop
yeah
dude
I was 300 no no If he if he had towed my
car it would have been 300 that's a pain
in the ass with 12 yards if you get if
you get a DUI you you're looking to
spend an extra probably like 10 to 20
grand depending if you get a lawyer
that's what I heard yeah because your
insurance goes up your first you get
kicked out of your insurance and you get
to get this other special kind of
insurance and then you can't drive for a
year
like you can only drive to and from work
school doesn't count getting groceries
doesn't count good so if you get pulled
over during that time you you got to be
drunk when you go grocery shopping well
it's more fun than that
what about you you got a DUI well no I
had to I had two I had two uh why are
you laughing at me that's [__] up dude
no way you'll get this lameo he doesn't
party
I got two uh ecstasy
ecstasy associations with driving oh
really yeah so one of them this was in
high school I was making a delivery uh
out to Fullerton from El Monte and then
the car that I was driving
um the engine just went out on the
freeway and I was like oh [__] so you
like power steering turns off everything
so I'm like on the five you know like
we're close to where like Cerritos is
like Harmony to exit and I have to pull
it all over like this and then I had
like a bag of maybe I'm like 50 uh
ecstasy pills and I was like oh [__] and
even when you're a kid you don't know
like what happens I'm like I need a call
to get my car towed does that come with
like cops was there [__] like police
report like what the [__] is going on so
I just like grabbed the Ziploc bag and I
opened it I'm on the side of the freeway
just
and that's a hell of money
yes a couple Grand worth oh my [__]
[__] oh my God call the tow truck and
they come and they pick me up oh there's
accidents
this is amazing yeah he tows my car and
then I'm like oh so the cops don't come
you've been like hey man let's turn
around I'll give you some money if you
can help me pick up all these parts
all the pigeons are all [__] up
no way what a waste okay
and I paid 80 bucks to get towed from
like Cerritos area all the way back to
El Monte and your suppliers like you did
what so there was that would come one of
them was um that's something I would for
sure do though and the one it was uh I
came out of a rave like still like
rolling like crazy and then
um you know when you're in high school
you don't really go to downtown that
much there's no reason to right but then
I'm trying to drive home at like 4 a.m
and then there's all these one-way
streets so apparently I was driving on
the wrong side of the road and a cop
pulled me over and then I was like oh
[__] I gotta [__] hide all these like
neon pacifiers and [__] and I was still
glowing and yeah
and then it comes to Justine and he goes
uh he's like where are you from they
always ask where are you from and I was
like oh I'm not from around here and
then um he was like you know you're
driving on the wrong side of the road
and I'm like oh I'm so sorry yeah I'm
from China that would have been a good
game
go on that street make the right over
here you're back on the right side of
the road as he lets him go he talks to
his partner he goes they don't know how
to drive
in China there's a right side
that's racist dude
but you know what though that's cool
because like that is that old joke about
like you know if for white people if the
cop pulls them over you don't you don't
like pretend you do anything wrong you
just go like oh hey how do you get to
like this one thing and then like
sometimes that convinces a cup oh yeah
yeah you just kind of go this way and
then you just take off too what it's a
dumb ass cop bro
like if we did that no way but like if a
white guy did that like oh hey how do
you get to like you know Disneyland oh
yeah yeah you're in the wrong City you
know what I [__] hate I hate when
cops think they did you a favor when
they're like let's say they pull you
over speeding you're like so I clocked
you at 95 put down 92. yeah [__] just
don't give me the ticket oh you know
sometimes that sometimes it is a favor
in which like I know there's like a
stipulation where if you're is it 25
over or 30 over it becomes reckless
driving right oh okay but still but
still though but still though just don't
give me the chance don't give it to me
just don't give it to me you're like
nobody goes slower in a construction
zone go [__] yourself dude in the far
left lane you're one guy gave me a
ticket once because I was in the far
left lane which is the Speedy [__]
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I'm just trying
to drive with traffic and he pulls me
over he's like you passed me I was like
but you're in the far right lane what do
you want me to do dude I'm in the far
left I gotta uphold traffic these are
the unwritten rules of the road and he
gave me a ticket one time I was driving
to LA and a cop pulled me over he goes
well what are you doing you're gonna
rush I'm like yeah trying to get to L.A
hahaha
dumbest question are you are you in a
rush aren't we all yeah dude like I know
sorry my job isn't to just drive around
foreign
they'll put a plastic diaper on you
[Music]